welcome to my home we're going to answer
some questions for you today I got all
your questions from the video you asked
a lot of good stuff we're going to go
through them for my helper for this
video we're going to use my sister
Sydney the lovely Sydney boo Shaq hey
guys you can call her the bid knee and
yeah so coffee on a Tuesday and 52 yeah
[Music]
all right you guys asked a lot of great
questions here
we're going to go through a couple then
we're going to answer as many as we can
as quickly as we can and hopefully we
can get through as many as possible who
is your favorite philosopher and why
Albert Camus Albert Camus the mist the
myth of Sisyphus and the rebel those are
the two that really have influenced me
the most name some not so popular
YouTube channels that you would
recommend well I have one Jeff that's so
popular I have one channel that I that's
really not so popular that I think you
guys would love it's called Nick poo
Shack oh yes Nick boo Shack check it out
our dad does a YouTube channel he makes
sand castles in the can in the summer
just just subscribe to him it'll make
them happy sports this is what I gotta
say about that
[Applause]
what is your favorite book you've read
in the past year The Fault in Our Stars
any advice for someone who is for lack
of a better term still searching for
what they love in life I think that if
people have a passion for something that
may not for example writing that's not
going to pay the bills that they just
they don't do it it might not pay the
bills that might not be the bills they
don't do it and then they just go for
the job that's gonna pay the bills so
yeah I think there's a lot of hobbies
that you get that you think that that
you just sort of enjoy you think you
could never turn it into a career just
because of the way that you were raised
or the way that you think everything
that you do that you love can be turned
into a career if you do it creatively
enough of the ancient Greek philosophers
who was the most awesome and why Plato
because he was the best writer how is
your brain the way your mind works
and your worldview different now than
when you were 18
what okay because now you're 24 I think
the big difference between that was your
hand the difference I think is that now
I am willing to be wrong to make someone
happy whereas when I was 18 I was
obsessed with being right and the truth
so true so now I think the best thing
that you can do you are all you always
had to be right the best thing that you
can do and learn the hardest thing to
learn is that sometimes it's right to be
wrong if it makes the other person happy
were you afraid of moving out on your
own and was it an easy adjustment no god
I wanted to move out so bad when I came
to college Portland Oregon so bad yeah I
just don't want to live at home anymore
I tell that to people and my
relationship with my parents has become
exponentially better since I moved out
so why the coop man get out yeah what
are your tips on starting a vlogging
channel good audio who is your favorite
Pokemon Charizard no question Charizard
he's the most powerful and you can't
beat him favorite movies Raging Bull
favorite movies anything by Tarkovsky
2001 a Space Odyssey Once Upon a Time in
the West huh look who it is what's a
movie duty
like are you progressive or conservative
are you democrat or republican probably
against this I'm a left-of-centre
Democrat which means really close to the
center but on the left basically exactly
what President Obama is do you follow
any other vlogs on YouTube of course I
follow the vlogbrothers wheezywaiter say
Frank
I love Nicki Dusek Nick poo Shack PBS
idea Channel I love Vsauce there's just
a few
Brierly Bishop great great vloggers
Emily people I aspire to be like how do
you prevent procrastination actually let
me answer that question later crass
Denis what is your driving force comfort
knowledge revenge for me it's friendship
name your top three bands The Beatles
The Beatles sly in the family stone and
Bruce Springsteen and the E Street Band
beer or spirits what's your favorite
poison
what scotch what are your religious
beliefs atheist what is your favorite
novel of all time and why the Viereck
own iam cycle by M John Harrison read it
my favorite book and the book that's had
the most influence on me people don't
know M John Harrison is and he's the
best writer of this generation if you
could live in a movie and be a certain
character in a movie for a short period
of time I still hadn't who would it be
and why I would be Rick Deckard in Blade
Runner why why not how important was
your education in your career let's talk
about grades well great to talk about
grades grades don't matter I've always
yeah I used to go on tours of my college
and tell the kids who are thinking about
going to be you that's great let's let's
let's let's break it down though if you
want to be a doctor a lawyer boy it
requires grad school grad school grades
matter well I see I when I discover
grades didn't matter I didn't really try
that hard in college um and then once I
discovered that what he said made sense
I didn't try that hard in college yes
and we both have great jobs now do you
believe in true love well it was three
talked about earlier I don't if you're
saying if you're asking do I believe
that love is true and real then yes if
you're asking do I believe in there's a
soul mates for it for all of us no no I
don't think there's so much there's not
a soul mates you don't think mom and dad
are soul mates no I think this idea that
there
like this other puzzle piece soul out
there for you to meet that's searching
through the world is insane and the sane
idea also I think that how to come they
saw so many met each other there's so
many people in the world they put the
God really put the puzzle pieces close
together advice for college freshmen and
aspiring writers okay here's my advice
for aspiring writers learn how to deal
with hating yourself writing that's
great event writing in the first weeks
and months is gonna be a lot of hating
yourself probably six out of the seven
days that you write if you write all
week you'll hate yourself
that number will slowly shrink over time
and what you can do is really look
forward to the days when you think your
writing is good but you're always going
to have those days when you think your
writing is terrible and a lot of what
stops writers once they start is not
being able to get through those periods
of days when what you what you think you
write is really [ __ ] cuz it is really
[ __ ] in the book maybe you should get a
second opinion
what if you think your writing is really
good but it's really not that good
always get a second opinion would you
rather fight one horse-sized duck or one
hundred duck-sized horses I think the
answer is obvious one wait one
horse-sized duck or a hundred duck-sized
horses a hundred duck-sized I think
there's no is no argument about this
it's a hundred duck-sized horses yeah
cuz you just mow them down right cuz
they're ducks I you take it you take the
golf and you score guys just [ __ ] mow
them down it would be so terrifying to
face a duck sized horse yeah or no it'd
be terrifying to face a horse sized duck
think about this a horse a horse sighs
yeah this is that's what it's doing
what is the bravest thing you've ever
done the bravest thing I ever did was
tell my friends that I love them why do
you have to make everything sound
dramatic like there was always some
deeper meaning to it when there is it
exhaust the bidding for staying in these
he asked me to do it thanks so much for
the bhindi for joining us for this this
is a lot of fun we're going to do it
again in the future I promise and we
will see you next time
next time
peace
[Music]
do you have any hidden talents I can
unicycle
hey that's I think that person just
wanted to tell me that naked unicycle oh
they said I yeah i cant u tas ichael
uh-huh
what can i know okay